haben
bitte lasst uns reden
ich will aber nicht mit dir reden auch
wenn du mich nach düsseldorf verfolgt
das ändert ist du kannst wie du mich und
was kann ich weißt du mit wem du
eigentlich reden müsstest du mit lotta
das habe ich doch schon
es ist sinnlos und außerdem will ich
lauter nicht zurück april lotter braucht
jetzt jemand die ganze sache mit ihrer
mutter hat sie ganz schön mitgenommen
was hat sie denn jetzt schon wieder für
bewegen
das ist es ja sie hat keinen diabetes
sind auch kein rheuma oder asthma diese
ganzen geschichten hat sie sich einfach
ausgedacht
es ist jetzt endlich raus gekommen oder
wo ist es so dass er ja ich habe mir
schon gedacht
ich habe ja sogar darauf angesprochen
diese ganzen krankheiten auf einmal und
dann zu dem zeitpunkt wo die geliebte
tochter aussieht es ist doch so dass die
ganze geschichte geht mich eigentlich
gar nichts an
es reicht
lasst mich bitte damit in ruhe
alles klar
nein
alex wann haben wir uns beide eigentlich
das letzte mal unterhalten weiß ich
nicht tut mir leid dieser klausel ein
paar job macht mich noch wahnsinnig was
für ein konzept soll ich denn jetzt
einbrechen
ach so ich fast dass mal zusammen
freundschaftlich verkehren wir also
nicht mehr miteinander und beruflich
auch nicht so dass du nicht du hast dir
meine vorschläge noch nicht einmal
angesehen
aber ich komm doch immer brav mit und
guck mir deine vorschläge an
ja aber du hast von vornherein deine
meinung die heißt alles ablehnen was
giorgio vorschlägt das ist überhaupt
nicht wahr
natürlich ist das war das weißt du genau
was bitte ich habe einfach keine lust
meine zeit zu verschwenden und einen job
zu machen bei dem ich nicht ernst
genommen werde
und du solltest deinen job auch ernst
nehmen und ich ständig diese
aufputschmittel schlucken das sind keine
aufputschmittel was dann mach macher
koffeintabletten die brauche ich damit
ich dass wir managen kann
weißt du was da einfach hilft einfach
mal ausschlafen dann klappt's vielleicht
auch mit dem managen
so habe ich jedenfalls keine lust mehr
mit ihr zu arbeiten ich kündige beim
praktikumszeugnis kannst du jeden fall
für jahres mir